The search for alien life
in the Universe
is one of the most intriguing quests
of our time.
From UFOs and little green aliens
to the possibility of life in the
underground aquifers of Mars,
there's no end to speculation as to
what form this life could take
and how it could have developed.
There's even a raft of videos
on the internet
speculating that aliens
must have visited
ancient civilisations on Earth,
because otherwise, how else
could the Mayans have built
their incredible temples.
Spoiler - there is no evidence
at all for this.
Frankly, if I was
a Mayan stoneworker from 250AD,
I would find it deeply insulting.
But a more interesting theory,
and one which has more credibility,
is that of panspermia.
That life exists throughout
the Universe
and can be transported through space
from one location to another.
Although it's certainly not proven,
a team of prominent scientists
from MIT and Harvard
have been working on a theory
that some form of life
was actually delivered to Mars
in this way.
Here's what we know.
Life is incredibly adaptable, just
look at the way our own species
has managed to thrive
across the globe,
and microorganisms,
such as archaea and bacteria,
over the course of millions
of years of evolution
have been able to modify themselves
in order to adapt
to a vast range of conditions.
This means that today there
are microbes that can survive
on a variety of diets - sulphur,
ammonia, the metal manganese,
and in the presence
or absence of oxygen.
Some even survive in the most extreme
conditions Earth has to offer.
Pyrococcus furiosus
(don't you love that name?)
thrives in hydrothermal vents
on the seafloor.
It's optimal growing temperature
is 100 degrees Celsius.
Whereas the Antarctic
psychrobacter frigidicola
prefers things decidedly chillier.
You can also find these extremophiles
hanging out in hot acid,
or surviving desiccation
in salt-crusted deserts.
And some of these microbes can even
deal with several extremes at once.
Deinococcus radiodurans
can be found in both hot springs
and Antarctic soil,
survive desiccation, and is one
of the most radiation-resistant
organisms we know.
So these extremophiles are probably
the most oven-ready organisms
to survive and, potentially, colonise
the hostile environments
of other planets and moons,
as long as there's liquid water
at least some of the time.
How would these tiny microbes
even make the journey
to these other places?
Well, the easiest way
is to hitch a ride with us
as we explore our
solar system and beyond.
Tersicoccus phoenicis
is a becterium
discovered in Nasa spacecraft
cleaning facilities.
Could we have already accidentally
introduced bacteria from Earth
to the Moon and Mars?
Another possible way
for these microbes
to get around the solar system
is by hitchhiking on meteoroids.
When these crash on a planet,
rocks and debris are shot into space,
generating more meteoroids.
So far, 313 Martian meteorites
have been found on Earth,
and an Earth rock
was also found on the Moon,
therefore we know there has been
interplanetary transfer of rocks.
Once in space,
the cold and lack of oxygen
are easily dealt with
by our hardy voyagers,
and even regular bacteria
can enter a state of dormancy
under extreme conditions,
creating thick-walled internal safe
rooms for their DNA called spores.
Heat, cold, acid, drought
and UV-resistant packets
of bacterial DNA
voyaging through space.
Another big problem is that space
is brimming with ionising radiation
that rips DNA to shreds.
Not a problem for deinococcus.
Clumps of this little fellow
have survived three years of exposure
to outer space.
Others have survived up to six years
in spore form.
Yet another problem is time.
Space is big,
so travelling anywhere
takes a long time.
That said, in 2020, Japanese
scientists revived bacteria
that had laid dormant
at the bottom of the ocean
for 100 million years.
So perhaps the extraordinary
distances aren't such a problem
for these tiny space travellers.
The final step is surviving the crash
landing onto your new home.
And bacteria have been shown
to be able to do just that...
As long as they are in deep fractures
in the cosmic rock.
So it's entirely possible
that microbial life
has already travelled
to somewhere like Mars.
Conditions there were remarkably
similar to Earth
3.8 billion years ago.
Could these extremophile microbes
have already colonised the
underground aquifers of Mars?
If they're already there,
have they adapted
to their new environment?
Or maybe life on Earth actually
originated on Mars
then travelled over to our planet?
They may not be little green aliens,
or intelligent life
as we understand it,
but the very possibility that life
could have transferred
across the solar system and beyond
is deeply intriguing.
And as the James T Webb telescope
begins its search
for tell-tale signs
of distant life on other planets,
could we perhaps find out that life
is far more inevitable
than we once thought?